would you date your dream guy if for two
days every week
your choice of the week or days oh thank
you she had to dress like a juggalo he
had to dress like a juggalo yeah that's
hilarious that is one time I dared my
ex-boyfriend for a month to wear a just
gigantic case on his phone that was this
rubber minion he doesn't like the
minions I've never seen the minions I
just saw the case and I was like could
if you wore that on your phone for a
month I'll pay you 500 but when people
ask you can't say it's a prank you have
to say I'm a minion man
and he did it he did it it made me love
him so much because what a weird thing
and he had just got a new job so he is
at work and had to like his boss was
like and he didn't tell anyone and he
went home and his sister was like what
is going on with that that case is so
not you and he's just like I'm just like
a minion man I'm into them and she goes
something's going on here and I'm gonna
find out what it is but yeah he got 500